coming out to meet the public who are
here a family together
the prince of wales has only recently
issued his statement saying that he will
do whatever he can
to fully support the new king
coming down from windsor castle the
great george the fourth gate behind them
and framing their departure now from the
private area and coming into the public
part of the park where the long walk has
often had
many royal occasions not least more
recently when the duke and duchess of
sussex were married coming out to look
at the
enormous number of floral tributes laid
here for the queen who spent most of the
latter months of her life here at
windsor castle she was here throughout
covid
it was here that the duke of edinburgh
died
and it was a very special place for the
queen and prince philip probably their
principal home
and for
their two grandsons to be here with
their wives
looking at those floral tributes
and
neither the
princess of wales as she is now nor
megan making the journey up to scotland
well they have families and
responsibilities and it matters only
that they're here now
in support of the king
and remembering
their grandmother
it is extraordinary the quantity of
contributions and things that have been
left by
members of the public to reflect upon
a queen whose reign was so
get
long
if
okay
hello
[Music]
okay
he's gonna go
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
in recent years and
i rather sense that for the late queen
knowing that her two grandsons are here
with their two wives
together supporting the king
and reflecting upon her and all the
kindnesses that have been shown in
reflection of the late queen's life
would be
very special to her she only really ever
cared that all the family
should be happy and she as was said by
the king she always saw the very best in
everybody and she will have done that in
particular with all members of her
family
all right alastair thank you very much
rhiannon mills our royal correspondent
is also watching these pictures with us
and
rhiannon it's uh
interesting that
[Applause]
uh
you'll be a great princess
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
as long as you guys
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
that's amazing
[Music]
hi guys
thank you
you're fine with that
yes
thank
you want to hold them
[Music]
yes
is
getting high down
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
yes
okay
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
i saw them
okay
[Music]
uh
oh
hey
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
thank you very much
thank much
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well you say that
[Music]
guys
thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
thank you so much
[Music]
okay
[Music]
yeah hello
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm a personal trainer
hello
[Music]
um
watch that
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
hello
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nice to
[Music]
of course keep breathing
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
yes
uh
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
you're right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we would
let you watch and listen to these
remarkable pictures we're seeing outside
windsor castle and uh
in so many ways they really do
speak for themselves don't they
the prince and princess of wales the
duke and duchess of sussex out to meet
the huge crowds
that as you can see there what a picture
that is stretching
down the long walk at uh
windsor these pictures also being
watched by our royal correspondent
rhiannon mills and uh
well rhiannon i mean with it
amid the great sadness
this will be delighting these crowds
i think at this most solemn of moments
this in a way will
bring a smile to many
it's been a moment that
so many people have wanted to see
a sense that you have two brothers who
in the past
were so so close
and have undoubtedly had a very
difficult couple of years a lot of
things have been said
since the sussexes decided they wanted
to step away from raw life
and yet
today we have them again
coming together and
so naturally once again
slipping into that sense of the royal
duty the royal role
and
carrying out one of those walkabouts
that you have to remember it was
actually the queen and prince philip who
decided they were the first ones who
went out and made sure that they met as
many people as possible
and here we see
two men who
have no doubt had their difficulties
in the last couple of years and
they've both come together really in a
mark of respect and i think to to get
out and meet the crowds and share in
this moment of
immense grief for so many
i understand that yesterday prince
william um the new prince of wales was
mulling over whether or not to to do a
walkabout of this sort um with his wife
catherine
and
it was earlier on today that he was the
one who approached
prince harry and megan and said look
would you like to to join us
when we go out there
and meet the crowds because of course
they are they are in essence now
neighbours because they live
both live in
cottages very large houses but cottages
on the windsor estate so harry and megan
who purely by fate happened to be in
this country of course they moved away
to america when they decided to step
away from raw life
when they were here in the uk which they
have been this week carrying out
engagements
they still have their base at frogmore
cottage
and only this week
william and catherine's children of
course have started a new school very
close to windsor and they have decided
to move the family out to adelaide
cottage and an awful lot was made about
were the two couples going to meet at
all
when the sussexes were here in this
country and
in essence what we were hearing was
there was no communication and they
simply weren't going to talk and and the
last time that we saw the sussexes in
the uk so the platinum jubilee
there were suggestions that there was
this frostiness that was still
continuing when we saw them at saint
paul's for that platinum jubilee
service the sussex is sitting in the
opposite aisle from the other senior
royals
but i think
what the queen always said
despite all of the difficulties that
were had
despite everything that was said while
she was alive
the sussexes she constantly repeated was
still much loved members
of the royal family
and so
in a way you get the sense that they are
they're doing it for her
they are
or two men
who over the years have
been united in grief
of course sharing the death of
of their mother
and now once again coming together
in this
incredible way which is completely
unexpected
to pay the ultimate respect to their
grandmother
[Music]
andreanan what is noticeable is
this is all generations here young and
old and
all out uh just wanting to
see the royal family to pay tribute to
the royal family to pay their respects
to the
to the royals
and we sort of get glimpses don't we of
those conversations that are being had i
think at one point prince william was
saying to some of the younger children
in the crowds have you heard of the
queen
um
and yeah there are smiles and and it
sort of resonates with this this feeling
that we've got when it comes to what
we've heard from the new king when we've
had his address to the nation last night
and also
the words that we heard from him at the
accession council where he talked about
how much it means to the royal family
when they are going through this
incredibly difficult time to know
that queen elizabeth ii was so widely
respected by so many
and in a briefing a couple of hours ago
we were told that
for the new king while yes of course
the state duties are very important at
the moment his main focus is going to be
leading
the royal family our nation and other
commonwealth realms in mourning really
wanting to make sure that he personally
gets out to meet as many members of the
public as possible to share in that
grief
here we also see
how
in a way other members of the royal
family it seems are gaining some
some solace
from from being able to
to talk to the crowds and you have to
remember this is something they weren't
able to do
when we saw the death of the duke of
edinburgh due to covet
and yet now because those restrictions
have lifted because we're living in
different times the crowds can come out
in windsor
and
prince william
kate
harry and megan
have now spent
gosh almost 40 minutes
obviously shaking as many hands as
possible
reaching out and grabbing those but
those bouquets of flowers we can see
megan there
handing over a bouquet and what's been
fascinating for me to watch knowing the
teams around them knowing
the prince and princess of wales's team
at one point i saw one one of their team
go over to megan and say
would you like me to take those flowers
from you i think there is this sense
look we're welcoming harry and megan
whatever's been said some of it said
very recently whatever's been said and
said very publicly in the press this is
a time
not for
family squabbles this is a time
to listen to what the queen
would have said would have wanted
she
always described harry megan as much
loved members of the royal family and as
the king last night mentioned he talked
about how the queen had this unerring
ability always to see the best in people
and
today i think
we are seeing how
the prince and princess of wales are
following her example and saying look
in terms of
family problems family turmoil this is
not the week to draw attention to that
this is a week to come together to
remember her
and also now support the new king
yes it's interesting we saw that
traditional side of the monarchy this
morning but here
right here outside windsor is the modern
monarchy in action
it is and
look the the
arrangements around
the death of queen elizabeth ii have
been
years in the planning and
and yes the ceremonial
was always the thing that we were
briefed about the certain events the
ceremony that would happen every day
today was was meant to be a day about
the accession council about that first
big ceremonial moment since the death of
the queen
in which we
saw the new king proclaimed as the new
monarch the pageantry around that the
celebration the fanfare
but also you have of course many people
still wanting to
pay their respects
and and mourn the queen
and there is no doubt that the way that
the royal family
in these pictures
in this moment
have spent
gosh almost 40 minutes speaking to as
many people as possible
this is what matters to many people up
and down the country
this is the way that
they connect and of course that
tradition
was started by the queen she was the one
who always realized that the royal
family must stay relevant if they're to
survive
and
it's been difficult it has been
difficult for the family we live in much
less differential times we live
in a time where the media have wanted to
know
about the relationship between
the cambridges and the sussex
and i think with this moment
the prince of wales the new prince of
wales we see there
almost getting into that car
for him
he made that decision that he was going
to ask
the duke and duchess of sussex to join
him today on this walkabout
and
in essence show that they are united try
to put to bed the questions that were
going to remain this week about would
the sussexes be involved
and
with this one move
with this
remarkable walkabout
we can see them now
everyone thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and there they go
getting into their cars
the two couples
who on the marriage of harry and megan
were
described as the fab four
who have had their difficulties
over the past couple of years
but today have been very much
united
when it comes to paying their respects
to their much beloved granny